همم الوضع متوتر على الارض همم في همم
باريس في اكثر من نقطه نتحدث عن نقطه اولى
فيها مطاعم للاكراد وايضا الاتراك ونقطه
اخرى حيث التجمع الاكبر بالقرب من موقع
همم عمليه وهناك ايضا محاوله من قبل
القوات الامنيه لفظ هذه التظاهرات اذا
الاكراد يثورون في باريس في الشارع يخرجون
للتعبير عن غضبهم عن استهداف الاكراد هذه
ليست المره الاولى مشاهدينا التي يتم فيها
استهداف للاكراد في باريس ولكن في المره
السابقه همم الوضع فيما يبدو كان يختلف
كليا وقد تم في حينها توجيه الاتهام
لالسلطات التركيه بان تكون او جهات تركيا
بالاحرى بان تكون هي وراء هذا الاعتداء
اما هذه المره همم فليس هناك من اشارات
حول ان هذا العمل هو همم ارهاب او ان هناك
جهات معينه قامت بتحريك هذا الرجل وزير
الدفاع الفرنسي وحاله وصوله الى موقع
الجريمه قال بانه تحرك بمفرده بمعنى اخر
بان ليس هناك حتى الان شبهات بان تكون
هناك خليه تحركت او يكون هناك من هو وراء
هذا الرجل